[Musique]
puis pour moi
j'étais vision
je les couche sur le papier les jambes
et pour les lire
il a dit que les landes donne avec tous
l'habitude d'être à déconnecter
de la réalité t t il le plaisir d'être
dans l'air
cliquez
[Musique]
juste à côté
revient
je suis en plein traquenard commence à
un traquenard
ah je piste que scott et son frère
avaient inventé une chasse au trésor
il fallait que je vienne en personne
pour essayer encore une fois ces offres
nous publier ses papiers doivent être
rassemblés il faut les examens il est
hors de question que vous voyez ses
papiers
elle refuse de me le donner je
récupérerai ses papiers peau
scott london ses livres m'ont changé
tu te rappelles le soir où tu m'a
demandé si j'étais saint blaise j'ai
fini par y croire voilà le pouvoir de
son imagination il existe un moment on
peut y retrouver
moi ce qu'on aime qu'est ce que c'est
fois qu'on a résolu toutes les aînés et
trouver tous les indices à une
récompense
est ce qu'il paraît
en droit pénal
[Musique]
ou c'était le fruit de mon imagination
cet instant
[Musique]
nestor
jetables
houas soir
il est parti et leur ait pas de pousser
leurs cours
[Musique]
est ce qu'il est un réel où c'était le
fruit de mon imagination
[Musique]